so the perennial question when a woman
chess player is interviewed is why do
women and men play separately
you must get all the time 100 times
absolutely and I mean it's so hard to
answer really because in your mind
you're also like why because it is there
I mean we we got you know we are still
you've got these top hundred players but
we don't have a female player in there
and that's what I get all the time is
that why is it that women are not as
good at chess as men is there is there a
difference because this is not a
physical sport and it's really really
hard to like understand that I think
firstly what it's it's a big number game
we have we have to understand the chess
in general is such a new sport for women
to take up as a career historically we
haven't had as many opportunities in
terms of profitable tournaments for
women you know just women only
tournaments where where you know that
there's this whole career in front of
you where you can make her make a living
out of it also social and culturally you
know at least where I come from that is
the big debate that there are these
almost like these pre describes roles
for women and and sort of a part that
they have to be on and then chess
doesn't fit into that so that comes in
at least from my part of the world a lot
of them sort of gave up playing and
stopped playing when they're in their
early 20s because they've got to get
married and have kids and do all of that
I think all of that is changing Bojan
yeah me too and the other thing about
that question is that actually women and
men do play together all the time almost
all the top players in the world women
also play and mix gender competitions so
sometimes when we ask that question why
do women play separately well yes they
play separately but only some of the
time yes right and the reason they play
separately some of the time there's like
a large variety of reasons for
professional players it's primarily the
chance to shine on the national stage
because you're outnumbered so if you
play in a mixed competition usually
we're not among the highest ranked right
and then secondly usually money right
there's usually good money and some of
these women's competitions particularly
in the United States where you have the
100k prize fund for the national
championship and now the 100
decay prize fund for the Karen's cup as
well the stipends for the Olympiad and
such so there's all these valid reasons
and then for the girls what I often say
to people is hey I mean at the youth
level it's not just about becoming a
professional chess player it's about
enjoying yourself and developing your
mind
and so if girls want to play with each
other I don't see anything negative in
a.m. but but the question really is I
mean if you take the example of the
kholghoor sisters or yeah who's your fan
or they when they started trust they
were playing a lot with boys they were
training a lot with boys and you know it
was not just so is that it's that
important to start from a really young
age to work inclusively and not
exclusively and I think that's true as
well
I mean you because because if the sport
is such the nature of the sport is such
that that you can work on it together
and then in the big picture when you
really want to be one of the world's
best players it's probably more useful
and it's probably better for for all
girls to actually work inclusively and
not exclusively yeah I think a
combination of the balls it depends what
you want to get from jazz yeah if you
want to be the best player in the world
certainly you got to start you know
playing against the best male players
and the best female players ASAP right
yes first some girls where chess is more
of like a springboard to becoming to
getting into a great college to being
comfortable focusing on one difficult
subject if that's the case then if you
enjoy playing against other girls and
building that you know right or wrong
it's just it's just what you want out of
it
but I do think that for the promotional
value of getting women and girls chess
more popular it is important to address
the question because otherwise people
they think it's awesome that there's all
these rock star female chess players
like yourself were not only great chess
players but also really cool and
interesting people but if they don't see
you also playing against men they
question and you do you playing in mixed
gender competitions as well but if the
majority of the times right right but
for some reason they're not aware of
that they might say well hey why is this
and it's it to them into the mainstream
it seems like a little bit like
confusing so I I do think it's important
to kind of answer that question with a
straight face
even if you get asked it a hundred times
right yeah and I think it's really
important for you know that's why
tournaments like the Isle of Man or
Gibraltar Masters where you've got women
players the top women players coming and
competing against the top mayors and
fighting for open prizes for women
prizes they're great for chess they get
so much they get so much attention for
chess when you've got you know you've
got you've got a Jew venture north
Katrina LA know who scores heavily
against one of the top guys and this is
what also encourages young girls to take
up the sport because they know that they
don't have to there's no there's no
gender barrier in the sport really but
it is true that the numbers don't lie
and the fact is that there is still a
lot of gap between chess trends between
female players and male players and the
question is then how do you change that
do you do you get rid of women titles
all together so that female young girls
are actually fighting for just the open
titles there is no women international
master title there's only an
international master title do you have a
woman Grandmaster title or do you only
have a Grandmaster title in the big
picture do we need to go in that
direction or not I don't think so Tania
because I look at via growth of American
chess and I see that some of these young
girls who play in separate tournaments
occasionally like the charissa hips who
are you know III can't end up fourteen
and twenty four hundred plus u.s. chess
so maybe twenty three hundred feet eh
but you see these girls getting really
strong ratings at a very young age and I
actually see these girls tournaments
that they've been participating in as a
boon because they bond with each other
they become friends and then they keep
fighting and they play more actively
both types of competitions I just think
that we're under estimating women's
intelligence if we say oh if you if they
have the women's Grandmaster title or
separate girls tournaments are gonna get
confused and think that's the same as a
Grandmaster title I don't think anyone's
confused they know that wgm is different
than GM and that while w GM is a
difficult title to achieve that the GM
is the ultimate right I do believe that
young girls were ambitious understand
as you were mentioning my master titles
your Altima call ya know and also I
think it's highly motivating I mean you
know in your in your journey when you
reach these these landmarks you know
when when a young girl takes up a sport
and then she reaches 2100 or 2200 and
becomes a woman international master
she's motivated to work towards becoming
an international master next or to
become a world grand master next and I
actually think that it's really
important to have that and to have the
other big the other big question is in
open events should we have women
category prizes when women are fighting
for the open prizes as well and I again
think that that's a really good idea to
have it because it actually encourages
more girls to come and participate if we
took all of that away I mean at least
for the next 20 years of the next 30
years I see so many women players just
losing interest in the game or young
girls I mean you have to change a whole
system for that to come into play and
does that even need to be does that does
that situation even each I don't think
so
I think rimas yutani because it's also
it's I think it's thinking very abstract
in a perfect world where women had as
much money as men and you know women
made as much money as men then you know
there would be no need for all of these
different events but the reality is
we're trying to encourage more girls and
women to play and we don't want to take
back all of these events and prizes in
my opinion because I think short term it
would have a really negative effect and
not bad things like the Karen's cup is
gonna have a positive effect by giving
making it easier for professional women
players to you know add a 20 min to
their calendar that's profitable that's
why I correct John and also it's not
just these elite players who are
participating in the current Cup who
will benefit from it but it's the
younger generation and the grassroot
level players who see tournaments like
this and aspire to be there one day so
it's got this entire effect throughout
the field absolutely so I mean honestly
my opinion is both like I love mixed
gender tournaments I love seeing people
like holy fun
say hey I'm gonna focus on playing
against the men because I'm the highest
rated player but then I also feel like
you get more holy phones if you promote
tournaments like the Karen's Cup and the
Women's Championship but Tim tell me one
thing because this is the other question
that I'm sure you get as well and I do
all the time being a professional player
do you think chess is a success
spot I think there's there's a you mean
is there sexism within the world yes
there is but there's sexism in every
world so if you sing chess is like a
reflection of the overall society yes
it's there but is it worse than the
overall world I don't think so I don't
think so at all actually
I actually think that just has a lot of
a lot of positivity in it as well I mean
if you talk to players they're extremely
supportive about women chess you you
might get a snide remark or two you know
that was a girl move to make or
something like that but if you can have
a bit of a thick skin for these things
and just ignore it I think overall the
big picture there's a lot of support for
women chess I mean even in tournaments
the you get invited if you're able to be
if you're around 2400 or 2450 player you
know you're invited to many many elite
events and it's very possible to be a
strong woman chess player much easier
and I don't think there's been a better
time then then today for that I totally
agree I feel like I see a lot more
feminism in the chess world and
positively we're very progressive in the
chess world right now and let's let's
just keep pushing it forward go power
[Laughter]